his next game is actually Nevada at
Notre Dame is that right Mike that is
correct and on the day before the
football night in America debut on
Sunday okay Wayman so are you playing
golf I am how could you tell the wind
gave it away Mike I'm quickly retreating
to the lighting show you guys not like I
just I pretty got to me a minute early I
don't have to speed are you all right so
Nevada at Notre Dame let me get this
right so thursday night you'll be in
Denver with us for Denver and Carolina
no no you won't okay yeah I as is in
your contract we can't be in the same
that is that is true that is true yes I
will I will not be there but I've got a
tape piece to add to your show on
Thursday and then i will see you from
Arizona on Sunday before the pats in the
cards and then I'll be coming there from
Nevada notre-dame which is who I've
never done a game in South Bend because
since I was working at ESPN it's always
been with NBC so I'm so fired up to get
there all right have you gone to a game
there no have not it is well we went
with the doughnuts last year USC notre
dame and right it's just the atmosphere
is great it lived up it lives up to what
you think it will the the people old
school mean you do walk into sort of a
time warp a little bit there and it's
great I'd like to heard from you once
you do it I'd love to hear what your
thoughts are after absolutely and you
know I live in ann arbor so a chance to
go to one of those college football
cathedrals like there are any sec and
it's just you never you never grow old
when you look at that field and you say
you know what they've been playing
football here for seventy eight min and
there are very few when you think about
sports there are very few of those
cathedrals left the forums gone the
Montreal Forum is gone Yankee Stadium is
gone Fenway Wrigley obviously Lambo
reconstructed Soldier Field same site
but the Bears didn't start playing there
until around 50s or I think early
nineteen sixty they used to play at
Wrigley they're very few of those places
left college football has them that just
adds to it for me we're talking to my
trick of NBC Sports now clear up the the
elephant in the room where what your job
was when you came to NBC of calling
thursday night games because it almost
felt like the NFL was saying no Mike's
not a we don't want Mike doing thursday
night but they entrusted you with Monday
Night Football so I mean you were kind
of caught in between there so I'm
curious how this played out and what you
were told going into this deal with NBC
yeah well what it was reported or
assumed the city was assumed that I was
going to do thursday nights once I left
ESPN to come to NBC but in fact that was
just an assumption that was made nobody
ever stated that or said that when I
agreed to the deal we figured that we
will work out whatever my NFL assignment
is there was 20 of real estate knowing
that NBC added the Thursday's in the
Sundays and one of the things that had
been discussed early on in the
conversation was will have you do the
sunday night says Bob will do the
Thursday's as everybody now knows so
that was sitting out there for a while
and we knew that and then the rest of it
was to be figured out as we got through
and the way it ended up it ends up with
the two preseason games two games at the
end of the year and the first part of
the nerd aim schedule while Dan Hicks is
doing the the end of the pga tour season
so the fact that I was going to be the
Thursday night guy was just an
assumption it was never anything that
was decided in advance and has created a
whole life of itself I I'm just glad
that people really care about what I do
in the fall but nobody in my house
really cares they're know you're home
again what what are you doing here so it
was nice to be the part of conversation
in fact an to be very honest the only
the only demand that i made in the
contract negotiation was the opportunity
to fill in for you with the danettes at
some point well over the next few years
that was the only demand at NBC would
not would not let that happen so
hopefully you can at some point Wow are
you sure you want to do that yes yes I I
want to hear about fritzie's
injuries like yesterday the Bianca
pretties yes yes I want to hear all of
that one here this witty repartee about
waiting to get hurt and you know I want
to hear you tell us for the 37th time
that you blew out your knees I want to
hear that Club that's too good well I've
blown it out five times Mike so that
means I've told you over 150 times about
blowing out my name that's exactly right
so so I look forward to that at some
point in the next few years working as
part of the extended dpco family you
were wearing Carolina were you were you
doing interviews for the Thursday night
game in Carolina I was spoke to cam
newton oh okay so you had a sit-down
with cam that will air on Thursday night
with the season opener what what was
what you wanted to get to and what did
you what did you get out of Cam Newton
well I I wanted to see what this what
the size of a scar was and how you are
portraying the healing of that scar and
it's going to come down to campus for a
lot of us even though he's done a
nickelodeon kids show during the off
season which is actually kind of
humorous and you've seen him here there
for a lot of us the last image was 13
questions over a hundred and fifty
seconds with the hood on after the
superbowl and pouting camp which goes
back to the first couple of years when i
think the record was 13 and 19 it was
the first lack of success that he had in
football and what I found was a guy who
I think understands that even if you are
crushed and disappointed you still have
to face the music and there's a better
way to do it and perhaps if he had 10 or
15 more minutes before he got to the
podium it would have been better he did
not use that excuse at all he owned it
it was honest about it and is talking
about the the potential growth from here
for this team and I think the bigger
thing I came away with this was Ron
Rivera's message to his team and he's
talked to other people around football
and other sports we don't start as the
NFC champs playing in the Super Bowl we
start 0 and 0 and the more our guys know
that right from the start the better
chance we have it getting back
after a few days to let it soak in what
do you think is the long-term effect
with what Colin Kaepernick is doing I
the long-term effect it's it started
some conversations now I think that you
played the sound the actual sound bite
yesterday I thought that was really good
because i think as is as is common
practice now we take an issue and we
find the hot take that best fits our
show our conversation point and we get
away from what the crux of what he said
was I think the paint main takeaway is
you have the right to protest and if you
do that that's great do understand that
your method of protest will alienate a
lot of folks and in a country it's very
divided one of the few things that we're
still all together on is for most most
people in America respect for the
country respect for those who served the
symbol of the flag stands for for a lot
of people the mothership said they're
not going to show this opening night
that monday night game if you were swell
doing monday night football yeah if he's
sitting on the bench during the anthem
and in all fairness to him they said we
don't show the anthem on TV you try one
on a second okay on a second thing they
don't feel the anthem on the second game
yes double header which is which is
absolutely drive I've we've shown when I
was there it was week we showed the
anthem all the time for the first game
and for almost every Monday night game
over the last two years we would show
the national anthem here you're always
in that situation where you're joining
that second game usually try to go right
from the end of one game to the start of
the next you're not going to leave the
end of I think it's Steelers Redskins
with a minute 12 left to go show the
anthem in San Francisco but they
certainly will roll it back in if not
immediately within three or four minutes
so I don't think anyone's not showing it
I think it's more logistics here than
anything would you do picture in picture
though would you do splitscreen let's
say you're you're ending that first game
and then you show the anthem live is
it's happening in the niners can i if
it's two minutes or
four minutes that doesn't really matter
if I would show if I was showing it lies
I would make it part of the pattern of
the shot you show you show the flag you
show the scene you show that the you
show Kaepernick wherever he is and then
you go back to showing other people
along the way to document the full story
just like your eyes would be in the
stadium everyone else is doing this he's
not and make that part of telling the
story within the national anthem I
wouldn't at steelers redskins 1713 with
a minute 30 left go to box it I mean
tonight you're gonna get an answer to
what happens yeah and now it will have
happened twice and will it happen a
third time by the third time what we
kind of know what what the drill is here
so i I don't I don't necessarily see it
as a big issue unless you bury it and
don't talk about it and I assume it will
be talked about within the first three
to five minutes of the broadcast mike is
st. Shaw and shown to mike is playing
golf do you want to hit a shot for us no
no i don't i'm actually this is as good
as it possibly get i'm walking nine
holes with my daughter he's playing high
school golf okay that's the cool can't
you just have to if you don't like a
give us a when Charlotte lets just hear
how it sounds I've walked away from the
from the T so I could do this I'm
waiting to play a par three i can text
Fritzi and give you an update on what I
see it's a hundred sixty four yards
slightly downhill a bunker at all around
par three with the wind blowing left to
right about 10 miles now I'm gonna take
7 I was gonna say you always take out a
little more Club Mike yes you don't you
don't want to deal with the bunkers here
too difficult green and I want you read
I want you to be I want Mike Tirico golf
announcer to analyze Mike Tirico go go
oh okay here we got pair of man let's go
up to Mike Tirico joins us Mike Tirico
comes up to the fourth oh this is really
a bad swing he gets way too far behind
inside and has to recur echt good thing
he has some athletic ability to get back
to the ball but very inconsistent ball
striker usually takes too much Club and
when he makes flush contact it goes too
far thus the reason for the 13 handicap
that he carries
carries it very poorly by the way say oh
he does here at number four all right
thank you will get back out to your
let's go to Peter Jacobsen at 16 Peter
Mike have fun with your daughter and I
will I will talk to you soon I'll talk
to you soon I'll give fritzy a full
update on number four after I'm done I
appreciate that thanks Dan I'm gonna
take the over on Tirico getting a bar
I'm gonna go up five I'm putting down a
five for you Mike that's nice it's very
kind of you thank you i could have put
down a six or seven the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience